[Music]
or send help to him and jaramillo
with his brief informative today, Wednesday
, November 11, the governor styps
slide gave a strong warning and asked
residents of the state to stay at
home due to the anticipated increase in cases
of the coronavirus the governor stressed
that  wants to give hospitals and medical centers a
chance to recover
from cases and be able to continue
contact tracing in his report Tuesday the
governor called the effort for the
next fortnight stay home 2.0 and
plead with residents to avoid leaving
their homes  more than necessary and
also that they avoid having meetings in
their homes and that they always wear their
masks in their places of employment
tomorrow will be a decisive day for the
school district the board of directors
will vote on the plan to reopen the
school campuses the public district
one  205-page proposal
Monday detailing the learning plan
as a transition to a mo  delo hybrid
follows health and safety guidelines and
also limits classroom capacity
to 50
% if approved students would return
to face-to-face classes starting January 4,
on the other hand, the
southern nevada health district will be offering
coronavirus tests  at saint james high school
with tomorrow and friday from eight in
the morning to twelve at noon or
until the tests are exhausted no
appointment is needed but the tests will be issued
to the first people who
arrive at the site
now we will pass with your prognosis  of the
weather a partially sunny day is expected
with a maximum of 60 degrees and
light winds of 70 degrees will return
by the weekend have a good day
I am salt and jaramillo and this was the
Spanish edition
[Music]